welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast my name is eric trexler i am the
special temporary primary host of the
show for today's episode i am joined by
greg knuckles he is currently the
permanent guest co-host for the time
being
if you like the show and you'd like to
support it there are many ways you could
do that
of course you could like rate or
subscribe wherever you happen to access
this podcast
you could join the email newsletter at
stronger by science go to
strongerbyscience.com
newsletter and sign up for that email
newsletter it's a really nice little
resource we send out a
little research updates from time to
time that are really quick and concise
and informative so it's a completely
free resource be sure to check that out
if you haven't yet
you could work with one of our online
coaches we have coaches who do
one-on-one virtual coaching for sports
nutrition and training and both
you can check that out by going to
strongerbyscience.com
coaching
you could use our discount code at
bulksupplements.com the code is sbs pod
that gets you a five percent discount
off of your entire order you could
subscribe to the mass research review
greg and i are co-authors along with dr
mike zordos and dr eric helms every
single month we put out an enormous pdf
reviewing all of the most important and
most useful findings from the exercise
and nutrition literature from the past
month or so every month we typically put
out about 130 pages of written content
usually covering at least a dozen new
studies give or take two video lectures
five or six audio roundtable discussions
so it's a tremendous amount of content
every single month and when you sign up
you automatically get access to the
entire archive and that is basically six
years worth of content at this point uh
and then finally you can check out macro
factor that's the diet app that we
created and it does have a free trial so
you can download it take it for a spin
and decide if you like it
all right before we get into the content
for today's episode i do want to mention
a few uh format changes and an update
about the upcoming podcast schedule so
we have two episodes left this season
you're currently listening to episode 94
and we will do episode 95 and then we're
going to take our summer break it's
going to be about six weeks give or take
uh and when we come back from that uh so
the these next two episodes and then
you know what comes after break we're
kind of reshuffling the format of the
show a little bit this is something
we've done multiple times in the past
we're kind of
constantly revisiting the show and
making adjustments as needed so for
episode 94 and 95 we're going to be
trimming the episodes a little bit
getting closer to the like 45 minute to
one hour mark we're also going to be
reshuffling these
i mean that's what we're projecting
we've we've said that before we'll see
how long they actually turn out to be
but but that that is our intention but
we have a strategic approach that should
facilitate that that's kind of my next
point we are going to be reshuffling the
segment selection a little bit so
instead of doing a set number of
segments every single episode we're just
going to be kind of throwing them in as
needed so for example feats of strength
typically we do it every single episode
moving forward we're just going to do it
when there's something particularly
bonkers that we feel like commenting on
but yeah it's going to be fewer segments
per episode but the same general
selection of segments that you are
accustomed to so they're going to be a
little bit shorter and uh yeah we we
hope you'll like it and then when we
come back from summer break i'm sure
during that summer break we'll revisit a
number of other topics about how the
podcast is formatted and uh we'll give
you updates as they're available
so
getting into the content for this
episode uh we're gonna do i'm doing a
couple q a's so responding to some
listener questions and the first one
i've got is actually a follow-up from
last week's episode so
in last week's episode i talked a little
bit about sauna and the fact that
sauna's a really fascinating uh
stimulus for for various adaptations uh
the way i i phrased it is that it can be
to some extent a bit of an exercise
mimetic where some of the physiological
responses and adaptations to sauna
exposure are almost like a very light
version of kind of low intensity
physical activity
but i did get a follow-up question uh
and by the way if you go back and listen
to that episode if you want like the
detailed assessment of sauna my general
conclusion was i wouldn't expect major
health related or performance related
benefits but basically you know you
might be expecting changes that are
neutral to maybe slightly positive but
overall it seems to be a very enjoyable
practice that that need not be
restricted or avoided but you know i
wouldn't expect major huge positive
health benefits from sauna independently
but i got a follow-up question from a
listener asking about how sauna might
potentially impact recovery from
exercise and their question was
basically
i've heard that sauna actually impairs
recovery from exercise and i've seen you
know some research to support that so i
wanted to briefly address that because
it is true
that there are as far as i'm aware
two acute studies reporting an
impairment of recovery from acute sauna
use so basically we're talking about
doing exercise then having a single
sauna session uh so sauna bathing for
you know kind of a typical finish
approach where you're getting in and out
maybe one or two or three times for
short periods of time
and they're looking at the effect of
this single sauna bathing session on
recovery over the next 12 to 24 hours so
we're looking at short-term recovery
with a single
sauna session so one of these papers was
rasanan and colleagues
and uh i'll link the uh the pubmed link
in the show notes and it is important to
recognize that in this study by rassinen
and colleagues they did report an
impairment of acute recovery from
exercise
induced by sauna but
there is a very important caveat if you
open up the full text and kind of dig
into the data so
they looked at a variety of different it
was a crossover trial with a bunch of
different conditions
uh and the the important caveat here is
that the conditions were not completed
in a randomized order so the kind of
control condition in this particular
study design was sauna only
rather than sauna after a particular
training bout
and for all individuals that sauna only
kind of control condition was completed
first and then they did the other
conditions after that and if you look at
the baseline values in that sauna
condition which again was always
completed first uh the values that they
saw there for the baseline outcomes were
pretty much the highest across the board
when you compare to all the other
conditions and again
this is a crossover trial so it's the
same exact people who are coming in to
do these baseline assessments for each
condition
and if you have an effective washout
period
and you have effective controls
regarding kind of
pre-visit guidelines theoretically in a
crossover trial you should anticipate
that the baseline measurements for each
of these conditions
ought to be approximately similar like
that would be the ideal scenario and if
you see that that's not the case you
would say maybe we did something
incorrect with
the washout period or the pre-visit
guidelines or maybe we didn't uh you
know randomize these visits
appropriately we've got some kind of
time related effect or didn't uh or
didn't uh adequately familiarize people
with correct with the strength tests or
performance tests yeah so with a
crossover trial what you would like to
see is
there's always exceptions to this but
generally speaking you would love to see
a randomized approach to study or to
condition ordering so that people are
doing these conditions in different
orders so that you're not seeing effects
that are totally related to the sequence
in which these conditions are completed
and you would like to see that the
washout period and the pre-visit
guidelines are
thorough enough and the familiarization
is thorough enough that every time they
come in for the next round of testing
and they do their baseline visit again
you should hopefully see relatively
similar numbers so in this case uh sauna
condition that control condition was
always done first
for all participants and the baseline
values tended to be highest in that
condition compared to all other visits
that followed and so
you know looking at the data you would
say oh it looks like in this sauna
condition performance was impaired 24
hours later but when you look at those
you know impaired values 24 hours later
they were quite similar to the baseline
values in all the other conditions so
it's very difficult to say after this
sauna condition
you were really screwed in terms of
performance because that level of
performance was indicative of just
showing up to the lab the other three
different conditions you completed
so um in that case i i don't think that
it's necessarily incorrect the way that
um the uh you know that people discuss
it
uh it's not explicitly incorrect but i
think a more nuanced interpretation of
that data would suggest that uh it's
very difficult to
to use that as a very clear-cut instance
of sauna impairing recovery directly
there was another study by skorsky and
colleagues
and again they found acutely an
impairment in exercise recovery
related to post-exercise sauna
but this was again a crossover trial
and that's a really valuable thing like
people always talk about crossover
trials being a great thing uh and as a
researcher sometimes you view it as
great because it's just
half the recruitment you know you can
say oh we can do two treatments but we
only need to recruit one group or three
treatments
so it is economical and efficient but it
also gives us some extra data that we
can use you know we can look at these
baseline values and get really
informative observations that we can't
we can't necessarily make the same exact
inferences when we have independent
groups yeah so if you have uh i'll just
get right to the point here and kind of
uh
contextualize this a bit so in the study
by skorsky and colleagues they did
report an impairment of recovery but if
you look at these two different
conditions so there was a sauna
condition and kind of a placebo or
control condition
and they did you know
exercise and looked at pre and post how
did how did these recovery metrics look
so
they reported that there was uh an
impairment of recovery after sauna so
pre-sauna to post sauna there was an
impairment but if you look at that
difference
it doesn't really seem to be meaningful
when we contextualize it based on
how different were just the baseline
measurements when these same individuals
showed up for the sauna treatment versus
when they showed up for the control
condition so like the effect size of the
uh the effect of sauna
really wasn't even as large as what you
would see as you know the difference of
just showing up for the other condition
which we assume is just kind of random
variation in the the outcomes being
measured right so specifically the uh
baseline to baseline difference between
the sauna and placebo condition was
actually
noticeably larger than the difference
between the post sauna value and the
pre-placebo value so after this sauna uh
intervention where you'd say wow that
was quite an impairment
the the post sauna value really wasn't
very different from just showing up the
next time for the baseline testing for
the control condition
so what i'm getting at here is when you
have a
crossover trial
you have this ability to look at you
know the the pre-test values in both
conditions uh you have this ability to
look at the post-test values in both
conditions and the change within both
conditions and we can make inferences
based on all of this information and we
shouldn't get too caught up on any
particular bit of information
without contextualizing it with the
other bits of information so what what
i'm basically getting at here is when
you look at
these crossover trials that indicate man
you're way worse off in terms of
recovery after the sauna interventions
if you just look at how these baseline
data compare across these conditions
it doesn't look like this theoretical
impairment is any more noticeable than
just kind of random day-to-day variation
of just showing up to the lab and seeing
what you got for these performance
outcomes so
the broader point here is
baseline measures in a crossover trial
give you really valuable data about the
stability and the repeatability of the
measurements being taken
uh and you can use that information when
you're interpreting the effect size so
like if you say man sauna really screwed
these people over look at how low that
post test value is
if the change from pre to post or the
difference between post sauna and post
control isn't really that much different
than just the baseline to baseline
difference we might just be looking at
some kind of
random noise and fluctuation and it
really makes it difficult to say wow
sauna really screwed these people over
this was a similar principle to the
creatine and dht paper right
yeah yeah so there was a paper where
there's a single paper indicating that
creatine
increases dht levels and it was a
crossover trial
and the reason people say that is
because
with this group of individuals from
baseline to post-testing uh i think they
had three time points but baseline to
after they started creatine uh dht
within that group went up significantly
and so people like damn like creatine
obviously increases dht it's going to
make you go bald but that increase was
mostly due to an unusually low baseline
value when these people just showed up
for the creatine treatment right so
when you look at the baseline data with
these same individuals in the placebo
treatment you can look at it and say oh
creatine didn't increase their dht they
just had unusually low dht levels when
they showed up the second time yeah and
so yeah that's another instance where
baseline differences within crossover
trials can be extremely informative and
we shouldn't discard that information
because
it really
can
influence your interpretation in a
positive way yeah i i just figured that
would be a good uh a good touch point
for for real sbs fans who yeah who've
listened to the full archive absolutely
yeah um so
just to round out this conversation
you'd say okay there's two studies
showing some modest impairments when we
contextualize it based on the uh just
kind of day-to-day variability that we
can see from a crossover trial doesn't
really look particularly strong or
impactful in terms of the the magnitude
of the effect
there are i should note two studies
actually showing enhanced recovery or
enhanced training adaptations
after multiple weeks of sauna so a lot
of times people are worried about this
acute cover recovery idea thinking well
if i can't acutely recover that's going
to screw over my training adaptations
that's bad news um but but the previous
two studies showing recovery impairments
they were looking at single sauna
sessions looking at 12 to 24 hours post
sauna
looking at that recovery but there are
two studies one by skoon and colleagues
one by kirby and colleagues both linked
in the show notes that actually showed
enhanced training adaptations after
multiple weeks of sauna and so a
question is you know perhaps there is
some
adaptation going on like maybe a single
dose of sauna
might cause a potentially small recovery
impairment for 24 hours but even over
the course of only two or three weeks
perhaps you adapt to that and the net
impact actually shifts to a more
positive direction that's possible
although i will note the subjects in the
rassonine study were experienced with
sauna bathing on a regular basis and it
was conducted in finland where sauna
bathing is extremely common so i'm not
sure if we can necessarily say that it
purely is just an adaptation thing uh
these are small studies there's very few
of them we probably shouldn't say well
let's make definitive conclusions based
on relatively scarce or sparse data
i'm comfortable walking away from this
saying ah there's some stuff saying
maybe slightly
just barely negative there's some stuff
saying maybe actually positive
i'm comfortable for the time being
mostly calling it a wash yeah and saying
we probably don't fully understand
exactly what the impact of that is and
we have some like
modest stuff trending negative modest
stuff trending positive
probably on average is going to wash out
to be fairly neutral
one interesting thing i will note is i
saw i found a survey of elite russian
endurance
track and field athletes so it was a
survey of 153 russian like very elite
athletes some of them performing at the
olympic level all of them at least
performing at like the national team
level
and almost 97 percent reported using
sauna bathing regularly as a recovery
strategy so they were using it under the
assumption that it was meaningfully
positive for their recovery um now i
link that in the show notes because i
think it's interesting i'm certainly not
saying like well successful athletes do
this so therefore it must work we know
that there are a lot of very successful
athletes who do things
in spite of their success rather than
things that directly contribute to their
success
however i do think sometimes when we
look at elite athletes and we're
wondering
you know for my kind of general training
purposes is sauna going to completely
just destroy my gains and completely
mess up my recovery
if you're finding it being used at that
level of prevalence in people who are
competing at that high level where the
slightest little difference in
performance becomes a meaningful
meaningful issue
i find it very difficult to believe
based on the rcts and based on the
observational evidence that sauna would
be just disastrous for your recovery
i i don't think that it's going to
meaningfully improve much
in terms of recovery or training
adaptations but after kind of digging
into this research i'm just not seeing
any reason to
uh go out of your way to implement it or
restrict it if your main focus is
recovery or training adaptations but the
one caveat i will mention uh i would not
as a general rule throw any unaccustomed
stressor into the mix if i had a really
important competition or training about
within the next 24 hours right so
whether it's sauna or something
completely different like
anything that is completely out of the
ordinary something that you are not
otherwise adapted to yet you probably
don't want to be throwing crazy
variables in the mix right before a
critical competition period
and that's something we've talked about
a million times whether it's
water cuts for power lifting weigh-ins
whether it's doing
acute stuff during peak week for
bodybuilding like you do not want to
just completely uh throw in a curveball
at the last minute and say boy i hope
this goes well yeah
yeah one one just kind of like general
point to make about this is i think that
there's
an inclination
to to want to just
be able to categorize uh interventions
as good or bad and so like if something
if done longitudinally uh maybe it has
positive effects then like ooh but
acutely might have negative effects so
like
ah man you said it's good but like in
this one context it's bad so like
how do i sort this is it good thing bad
thing
and i think that it's uh
i think it's always important to keep
time course in mind like are
are you proposing that something is
beneficial short term long term are you
proposing that something is harmful
short term long term
because like you know in in this case
you know let's just take everything at
face value and say saunas are
deleterious for recovery like 24 hours
after a training session
but they are also beneficial for
longitudinal adaptations like those two
things don't conflict like both things
could be true like a great example of
that is just resistance training in the
first place like if if you're
you know if you're training basketball
players and maybe you have them do a
simulated game
and then the next week you have them do
a heavy high volume squat workout the
day before a simulated game you're like
oh [ __ ] squatting made them a lot worse
in that second simulated game therefore
basketball players should never do
resistance training right like i think
everyone listening to this
would recognize that that's
an insane conclusion to draw
but i think that there's
you know for for things where their
long-term efficacy is less immediately
obvious i think that there is sometimes
an inclination to just try to sort
things into
good bad not you know maybe good
long-term but deleterious short term or
you know the the opposite like good
short term but deleterious long term so
yeah you know just just keeping just
keeping time courses of effects and
adaptations in in mind is always very
helpful
yeah and i i kind of got into the
into the details a little bit using some
research specific terminology but
ultimately the conclusions are are quite
simple i mean like you said the the
metaphor or the analogy that you
constructed there is
is really perfect for looking at the
time course acute versus chronic so
that's a very simple interpretation
that's quite useful without getting into
a bunch of research jargon and then a
kind of a more simplified approach of my
assessment of those crossover trials is
like okay so you're saying sauna jacked
up your recovery and it screwed you over
so those out the way you're performing
in that totally screwed over state
is that meaningfully different from when
you just showed up next tuesday and if
the answer is no
you probably weren't that screwed over
yeah right like so that's really the
simplest interpretation of what i'm
getting at with these baseline crossover
values is like
in your most completely screwed over
recovery impaired state is that
different from you just showing up on a
different thursday and if the answer is
no
i don't think you were that screwed over
yeah yeah all right so uh moving on greg
you've got a segment about plyometrics
i do so
eric i have a question for you okay okay
before you looked at at the outline for
this episode if i would have asked you
how effective
do you think plyometrics are for
hypertrophy how would you have responded
uh i i would have said that they were
not very effective at all for
hypertrophy and and that's even become
like uh
a common thing in fitness right it's
like you
it's not unusual to see the hypertrophy
focused fitness types
kind of mocking the folks who do
plyometrics in the gym and it's like
dude you're spinning your wheels like
why are you doing all this crap like
that's for athletes yeah exactly so i i
would have assumed the same thing i i
didn't think that plyometrics did
anything for hypertrophy yeah uh and
that
that assumption uh may have may have
delayed me learning something uh
potentially interesting and useful uh
but
so the reason that i assumed that
plyometrics probably didn't do anything
for hypertrophy
is that most of the
most of the mechanisms or or like
predictors of hypertrophy that people
have proposed over the years
just either implicitly or explicitly
assume that accruing some amount of
fatigue is important for hypertrophy and
like the whole point of plyometric
training is you do little enough of it
that for all of the reps like
quality is good performance is good like
you intentionally aren't trying to
accrue a lot of fatigue but yeah so
things like uh the concepts of like time
under tension training volume volume
load uh the more recent quote unquote
effective reps idea all of them
either implicitly or explicitly assume
that accruing fatigue either during a
session or during a single set is
important for the hypertrophy stimulus
and a lot of the like so-called advanced
resistance training techniques also
again either implicitly or explicitly
assume the same thing so things like
drop sets rest paul sets mio reps like
they they all seem to implicitly assume
that accruing
like for advanced lifters maybe you
can't even accrue enough fatigue during
a set to failure for it to be a good
hypertrophy stimulus so you need to do
multiple mini sets to failure or drop
weight and take sets past failure so you
know all of those things are as far away
from plyometrics as you can get so yeah
i just assumed plyometrics don't do
don't do a thing for hypertrophy
and uh
so so like i mentioned just how
how strongly i assumed that
may have kept me from
learning something interesting so in in
2019 i believe 2019 or 2020
there was a a systematic review from
gurgic and colleagues that showed up in
our monthly journal sweep the title was
effects of plyometric versus resistance
training on skeletal muscle hypertrophy
a review
and i saw that title
and i just said
well i know what the answer is i'm not
even going to read this um because
because like there are occasionally
systematic reviews or metas in our field
but
you know it's it's good to have a
systematic reviewer meta on the topic
just just to summarize the evidence that
we currently have but kind of everyone
knows how it's going to shake out so
like this
this same researcher gurgic like
previously i already know what you're
talking about you know exactly what i'm
going to say he previously did a
meta-analysis quantitatively comparing
the hypertrophy effects of resistance
training and aerobic training
and like
that one was not a surprise resistance
training way better for hypertrophy than
aerobic training and so i was like
despite what everyone's saying right
right so i was like okay plyos versus
resistance training this is gonna go the
same route so like i saw the title of it
and i'll admit i didn't even bother
skimming the abstract i was like i know
i know where this is going um
and so uh you know another year or two
went by
and then a couple more metas showed up
in our monthly journal sweep that
weren't directly comparing plyometric
training and resistance training but
were just
looking at the effects of plyometric
training itself on hypertrophy so i was
like okay that that is potentially
interesting i'll uh i'll i'll look into
this like i'll check these out so the
first one was by
uh della cruz and colleagues the title
is effects of plyometric training on
lower body muscle architecture tendon
structure stiffness and physical
performance a systematic review and
meta-analysis
and so this meta included 32 studies
and it found that uh it found that
plyometric training did have a
a small to medium-sized effect
on uh gains and muscle thickness so
a standardized mean difference kind of
like a cohen's d effect size ish of
0.59
and that's pretty noteworthy because the
effect size it found for hypertrophy was
actually basically the same as the
effect size it found
for improvements in jumping performance
and strength performance uh so those
were effect sizes of 0.61 and 0.57 and i
mean the whole point of doing plyos
typically is to jump higher and so this
found that like
quantitatively so you know not not in
terms of like percentage figures or
anything like that but in terms of like
how many
standard deviations the
the subjects improved by uh it was
pretty comparable for hypertrophy and
jumping performance which which is
pretty noteworthy
uh and then and then more recently like
just in the last month or two uh there
was another meta-analysis by arts and
colleagues
all of these will be linked in the show
notes uh but uh the title of this one is
effective plyometric jump training on
skeletal muscle hypertrophy in healthy
individuals a systematic review and
multi-level meta-analysis
and so this one uh wasn't completely
dissimilar from from the de la cruz meta
but it did have
uh it did have tighter inclusion
criteria um you know going through each
one with a fine-tooth comb probably not
worth our time here but this one was
a smaller meta in terms of how many
studies were included but it was
probably a higher quality meta-analysis
so this one included 15 studies so it
still wasn't like a super small meta um
and it found that uh it found that uh
plyometric training did still have a
a noteworthy effect on hypertrophy so an
effect size of 0.47 which again is is
like a small to medium
size effect it found that that effect
was present both for
uh athletes
and for
uh like untrained non-athletes so for
for athletes the pooled effect size was
about 0.33 which you know is smaller
than the overall mean effect but is also
a non-trivial effect like that that is
still like meaningful hypertrophy uh and
for the the untrained non-athletes it
was an effect size of about .55 and also
a really cool thing to see from this
meta is they did a sub-analysis to see
whether
like basically whether the effect was
mediated
by how high quality of measurements
studies used so some of these studies
did directly assess muscle hypertrophy
uh you know looking at things like
muscle thickness or cross-sectional area
using ultrasound
and uh some of them just kind of
estimated hypertrophy using uh
estimation or prediction equations so um
in in labs that you know don't have the
resources for an ultrasound unit you
might see a study that tries to assess
hypertrophy just looking at like limb
circumferences like you know d
did your flexed upper arm circumference
increase by
a quarter inch or something um and and
some of them maybe will try to estimate
quad cross-sectional area by taking like
a thigh circumference and also
a skin fold thickness to estimate like
the size of the layer of fat over over
the muscles so you know those are
um you know those measurements don't
mean nothing but they're they're not as
high quality of measurements as say an
ultrasound measure of thickness or
cross-sectional area and so this meta
found that actually the effect size was
larger for studies that had higher
quality measurements which if anything
you often see the reverse like maybe in
in a meta like things that use kind of
imprecise measurements we'll find like
ooh whatever treatment we're looking at
is really really effective and then as
soon as you study it with higher quality
measurements you're like yeah maybe a
little bit less effective yeah so this
meta actually found the opposite so the
the studies with higher quality
measurement tools actually found
plyos were more effective for
hypertrophy which which is cool to see
and so um you know these are now two
metas finding that uh plyos themselves
seem to have you know not a not a huge
effect on hypertrophy but certainly like
a a notable non-trivial effect and so i
would have expected honestly like like
basically nothing
nothing more than like jogging right
yeah which is not zero but
is pretty close to zero yeah for sure uh
but no so it seems like uh independently
plyos do do call some hypertrophy and so
uh after
after looking at these two metas i was
like well maybe i should go back and
look at that gurgic systematic review
like me maybe i did skip it uh
like i should have given it a fair shake
and so i went back and checked it out
and uh it was also very interesting so
there there were kind of two
uh
i can't really say analyses because it
wasn't a meta but but there were two
groups of studies that were summarized
and one was
studies that were just directly
comparing head-to-head resistance
training for one group plyos for another
group
and in all six of those studies there
was no statistically significant
difference in lower body muscle
hypertrophy between plyometric training
and resistance training uh the other
group of studies they looked at in i say
group but it was just two studies it was
studies comparing
lifting alone to lifting plus
plyometrics so one group would just do
lifting resistance training the other
group would do resistance training plus
plyos and so in those two studies uh
lifting plus plyos didn't lead to more
hypertrophy than lifting alone so it
didn't seem to be an additive effect
um
but you know the the first analysis like
just head to head lifting versus plyos
seems to be
fairly similar
so the the standard caveat here is that
most of the studies in all of these
metas used untrained lifters
um
however i i think that
when i say that the the first place a
lot of people's minds will go is like
well okay this this is completely
pointless uh you know new lifters will
grow from anything so
uh why should we care
and to that i would say like i don't
think that fully gets you off the hook
because while new lifters
do grow some from from pretty much
anything uh they don't like this is the
important point they don't grow equally
well from everything um
like
most of the metas in our field
predominantly use studies on untrained
lifters and they find
very frequently that one intervention is
better than another um so
even though like you would expect just
about anything to cause at least some
hypertrophy for completely untrained
folks
you shouldn't expect like not not
everything causes a lot of hypertrophy
for untrained folks like not not
everything works equally well uh and
also the the de la cruz meta or the the
arts meta i mean um
did did have five studies on athletic
populations so
you know either people who
were probably doing some resistance
training for their sport or who
at least had done enough kind of like
plyometric type stuff just from
practicing and participating in their
sport that their lower body musculature
was at least somewhat trained at
baseline regardless of
how much or whether they were doing
resistance training and even in that
group of five studies they did find
a small but significant effect of
plyometric training on hypertrophy
um
so yeah i think that uh
i still think that this is that this is
pretty pretty noteworthy and that this
body of literature does show
that
uh plyometric training
is is a meaningful hypertrophy stimulus
like i'm not claiming that it's
uh better than resistance training but
it does seem to
like independently have a a small but
notable effect on on muscle growth
and i find this pretty noteworthy
because to me at least this suggests
that there may be
some unknown mechanism of muscle
hypertrophy that
we don't know about and aren't really
looking for
um because like you know the the main
mechanism people are looking at these
days is just mechanical tension and
there's certainly mechanical tension
with
with plyometric training
but
it at least like there won't be nearly
as much concentric tension as there
would be for resistance training just
because like if you've seen like a force
velocity curve you know you're moving
your body pretty quick when you're doing
plyos and you can't generate that much
tension when you're moving at high
velocities like it's it's just not
possible um and also like there's
there's not going to be nearly as much
metabolic fatigue doing 10 jumps as like
a 10 rm squat so
you know the the the fact that this is
causing a fair bit of hypertrophy
even though it's not it doesn't seem to
be tapping into
the main mechanisms of hypertrophy that
people are talking about both in the
fitness industry and in the scientific
literature um suggest to me that like
maybe there's some other driver of
hypertrophy that we haven't found that
maybe we should look for uh which which
i find very exciting
a potential counterpoint or rejoinder to
this idea is that you know just looking
at at mechanical tension
uh there is going to be quite a bit of
eccentric stress with plyos and quite a
bit of eccentric uh uh muscle tension
generated and we know that that
eccentric training can be a potent
stimulus for hypertrophy so it's it's
possible that that's all that's going on
just from
kind of absorbing
the force of landing for each eccentric
or for each jump or whatever is the
thing that's causing the hypertrophy but
i don't know that personally at least to
me that that still seems like a stretch
because even though there will be that
tension that eccentric tension from each
landing that is still like
it's not that much you know like like in
in terms of magnitude it's a lot but
each contraction is still just so short
um
it seems like it would be
way way way less stimulus than you'd get
from really any form of resistance
training so
uh
yeah it
in terms of what we know about
mechanisms of hypertrophy yeah it seems
like plyo should do [ __ ] all right but
like
they seem to work kind of well which
which is interesting um
so so to be clear
uh in terms of takeaways from this
segment
i definitely don't think plyos are any
sort of silver bullet for hypertrophy
and also even though the the gurgic
systematic review found that in those
six studies that directly compared plyos
in resistance training even though that
sample of six studies found them to be
similarly effective
i am not
personally willing to go quite that far
um
and certainly for trained lifters like i
think that you probably can build some
muscle with plyos but i don't think
you're going to be able to develop an
olympia level physique just with
plyometric training like you know that
that would be kind of the
the literal expansive extrapolation of
those findings and i am certainly not on
board with that uh and just practically
speaking there's
there's a pretty finite number of muscle
groups that you can train effectively
with plyos like theoretically you could
rig up machines to train just about
anything plyometrically but
you know in terms of what's
feasible for the most part it's it's
jumps you know so you're training your
quads maybe your glutes definitely your
calves
you know but but how would you do
well
i was going to say how would you do
plyometric training for your biceps
there is a jim stephanie video for that
which uh maybe we can link that in the
show notes as well one of the funniest
things i've ever if you put it in there
i'll include it okay uh but yeah like
how would you do plyometric training for
like
i don't know
your abs like i don't know so yeah you
can't train every muscle effectively
with plyo so you could do like the like
ball throws and stuff like that i guess
but yeah it's very different yeah so you
know
even if it was just as effective as
resistance training you're still going
to have to do resistance training
because you just can't train everything
super effectively with plyos um
and finally just to reiterate in the
handful of studies that have tested
lifting plus plyos with lifting alone
lifting plus plyos didn't seem to have
any additive effect so if you're already
doing a lot of resistance training
adding some plyos in probably won't hurt
your results but it probably won't help
them either at least not not to any
notable
extent
uh but i i did still think this was cool
to see
primarily just for the mechanistic stuff
like i do think that this suggests that
well i mean
we know that there's plenty of stuff
that we as a species don't know about
skeletal muscle yet and this this kind
of hints at one more that like yeah
maybe the the mechanisms of hypertrophy
picture is
more complicated than we realize and
maybe there is some other mechanism
lurking out there that we don't know
about yet
um
and i also think that this is
helpful information to know uh you know
maybe if you have to take some time out
of the gym
uh or
you know maybe you're um like you have a
lower back injury and you're like ah man
like i don't want to lose a ton of
muscle in my legs but it's can't really
load the spine so like squats deadlifts
that's going to be tough what can i do
maybe you could just do some plyos and
if nothing else should be effective for
just helping you maintain what you
currently have uh and i also think that
this bit of information helps
offer an explanation just for something
you see in the real world like um
athletes in in power sports and sports
with plyometric components uh even if
they've never done resistance training
oftentimes they have pretty good lower
body muscular development already like
before they even touch a weight and and
i could very
feasibly see this being a key reason why
like they're they're doing enough
plyometrics just practicing their sport
plyometrics
you know probably aren't a training
stimulus on par with resistance training
for lower body muscular development but
they are
ineffective training stimulus for lower
body muscular development and so you
know these
if you see like high school athletes
with pretty jacked lower bodies who've
never touched a weight
uh
i wouldn't necessarily count them
untrained like they've they've done
plenty of plyos for their sport and
that's probably one of the reasons that
they do have pretty robust lower body
muscular development uh before they even
get into lifting
yeah yeah i think this is a good example
uh that kind of ties back into
discussions we've had about
empiricism versus rationalism you know i
think it's very intuitive in fitness to
assume that
everything that makes sense is true and
that everything that is true should make
sense
uh
and sometimes that's just not how it
goes you know like so that's why we
often
discourage people from being too overly
confident in arguments that are like
well theoretically this approach to
training makes sense therefore
it's probably true like that's that's
good and that's a useful
way to approach things for which we do
not have human evidence we don't have
empirical data that we can actually use
but yeah like from a rationalist
perspective like you and i both go into
this question saying no plyometrics are
going to be trash for hypertrophy
um well it's lyrically that's not the
case it's like based on everything we
know about hypertrophy it doesn't seem
like it should be an effective stimulus
yeah but then kind of the inverse of
that is that
if it does prove to be an effective
stimulus that means that there might be
something that we don't know about
hypertrophy exactly yeah and so it's
always like it's it's good to
form working understandings based on our
current knowledge right that kind of
rationalist perspective of like well we
don't have all the empirical
observations we could ever want
therefore we're going to have to lean on
theory and kind of piece some things
together tentatively
but it's important that you always treat
those things as being truly tentative
pending
further uh influence from empirical data
when it becomes available so like for
for this you know from a rationalist
perspective i there's no way i would
have expected plyometrics to be this
effective for hypertrophy uh and
the empirical data would suggest hey
there's there's something there you know
and yeah so you got to get back to the
drawing board and it's not just one or
two studies like it's
15 30
human trials on it like it's it's kind
of at the point where
you
know not to speak in absolutes but like
i feel like you kind of gotta accept it
yeah um like because it's it's not just
one of those things where it's one or
two papers and it's like ah let's let's
wait and see for more to roll in like
there's
there's more research on this topic than
i realized and it um you know it seems
to paint a pretty clear picture leaning
in one direction and in that direction
being yeah plyo's reasonably effective
for hypertrophy yeah it's also like you
know sometimes like you mentioned the
the kind of start of this conversation
is jumping to conclusions about a
meta-analysis of like oh that this at
the surface level that research question
doesn't seem very interesting therefore
i'll skip it
um but you know i was reading a
meta-analysis by james steele recently
about um
uh steady-state cardio versus interval
training
uh looking at different effects on fat
mass lean mass and things like that one
of the things i thought was really uh
really helpful with that meta-analysis
was they did the direct comparison uh
between these two different types of
cardio but they also did as kind of a
supplementary analysis independently
what is the effect of
steady state cardio on lean mass or on
fat mass and then independently what is
the effect of interval training on lean
mass and on fat mass and so sometimes
you'll find that meta analyses have a
lot more to offer than just the kind of
highlighted research questions sometimes
you find secondary and tertiary analyses
that are actually useful in other
contexts and other applications so
yeah i i the one thing i've learned over
the years one of the things i've i've
learned is that a meta-analysis can
often offer you a lot more information
than is kind of build on the uh
on the like headline you know so
uh yeah so that's very interesting and i
probably won't be incorporating any
plyos but it's good to know that they're
on the menu right yeah
um all right so i have a really quick
conversation i want to have a quick
little discussion uh to wrap up the
episode that then i'll play us out here
but i got another question about
something from last week's episode so i
believe it was last week's episode that
you mentioned you were on vacation and
you kind of ate intuitively
but that was presented within the uh
road to the stage segment which is
obviously kind of a longer term weight
loss
journey so to speak
and so i got a question from someone
that was a really good question they
were like well how is it that greg can
say he ate intuitively on vacation when
it's taking place within the context of
a broader weight loss goal
uh and it gets to the um
it kind of opens up this conversation of
what is intuitive eating so like what is
the definition how is it used in
research and then how is it promoted by
the people who came up with it and how
is it embraced by certain communities
that really identify with the concept
and i think it's important to recognize
that those are all very different things
the explicit definition of the
intervention how it's addressed in
research how it is presented by the
people who came up with it and kind of
popularized it and then how it's
embraced within different communities of
individuals so i
after that question there are other
questions about you know well how does
health at every size factor into this
how does uh body diversity and body
positivity mindful eating how do all
these things
factor in
is this just going to be a review of
wittgenstein's uh idea of language games
no because the the that's that seems to
be exactly what you're getting at with
with this setup no i have no idea what
you're referring to but i what i want to
do is talk about what these um
interventions actually explicitly are
and how they might be incorporated in
different contexts because
in a lot of cases it's like
do you believe in
the concept of making any intentional
inch change to your diet or do you
believe in mindful eating yeah or
intuitive eating and i want to just kind
of get into what the research says these
particular interventions are and how
they might be used because you know
sometimes people will wonder like okay
you guys have an app that does have you
know you can choose a weight gain goal a
weight maintenance goal or you could
choose a weight loss goal and so how can
someone who offers the option for a
weight loss goal
uh
be on board with concepts like mindful
eating intuitive eating and even just
like embracing body diversity and body
positivity you know so i wanted to have
a kind of a broader discussion about
what these things are and how they fit
together
so first of all
uh
mindful eating this is a really uh
a term that's getting more and more
popular over the past couple years
mindful eating is really simple it is
the act of paying attention to food
during consumption so
another way to phrase that is having
sensual awareness and focusing on the
experience of food intake so taking
stock of your senses as you're consuming
food and the goal for most mindful
eating interventions in the research is
not explicitly weight loss
it has been applied to weight loss
interventions but what you're trying to
do there is become more aware of
internal and extort and external cues to
eating right so you're just trying to
kind of bring yourself into the present
moment during eating and assess the
different cues that are are
occurring during eating you know am i
eating in response to my environment a
particular stimulus am i focusing in on
the flavor and the aromas of this food
or am i just watching tv
and just mindlessly kind of consuming
things without really experiencing those
senses along the way
and this does tie into
uh various
other concepts in the eating research so
like there's been nutrition research
looking at the texture of food and how
it impacts the amount we eat
or
you know the time it takes for us to eat
or our attentional focus during eating
and generally speaking it looks like
mindful eating paying attention to the
process of eating and fully kind of
immersing yourself and focusing on the
flavors the aromas eating slowly and
taking your time with it it does seem to
kind of
without any intentional restraint it
does seem to enhance enjoyment of a meal
and reduce the total amount of energy
consumption
so mindful eating is something that is
not explicitly a weight loss
intervention but it can be utilized
as part of an intervention where weight
loss does occur
and what you're trying to do there is
slow down prevent mindless eating take
your time with the food experience the
flavor and the aroma and in many cases
uh
noticing the sensations of eating and
being focused on eating rather than
distracted does seem to kind of
unintentionally
curtail energy intake to some extent
now intuitive eating
is very very focused on cues it's really
focused on eating based on physiological
hunger
stopping eating based on satiety cues
and seeking out foods that are
compatible with what you are really
drawn to in the moment so intuitive
eating
really is kind of an exploratory process
of figuring out when i eat
why do i eat
when i stop eating what what is actually
convincing me to stop what is dictating
my selection of different food choices
so intuitive eating is really about
getting in touch with cues emotions
and
stimuli that influence our feeding
behaviors whether that comes to the
decision to start eating the decision to
stop eating the amount we eat and the
things we choose to eat
so again
the the three central factors here um
it's it's giving yourself permission to
eat when hungry you know giving your
yourself some permission to have
flexibility with food selection
eating for physical reasons rather than
emotional or environmental reasons uh
and then relying on your hunger and
satiety cues to kind of dictate
the onset and the cessation of feeding
and so again
intuitive eating is not something that
is explicitly a weight loss intervention
it's about kind of reconnecting with the
cues and stimuli that inform your eating
behaviors and so
a lot of people who embrace mindful
eating and intuitive eating treat these
as things that are directly counter
to the concept of making intentional
food choices
to alter
health performance body composition etc
and i don't think they necessarily have
to be framed that way i think that you
can utilize these
these different strategies with a
variety of different goals and context
in a way that can be really constructive
so for example you know there most
people who do intuitive eating do not
track calories or macros and you would
think on the surface level there's
really no way to make that work but i
would actually disagree with that
so for example i'm not saying that
everyone who does intuitive eating
should be tracking calories or macros in
many cases they are using intuitive
eating because alternative strategies
might be contraindicated for their
situation
however
i think it could be really informative
to embrace intuitive eating and mindful
eating to take stock of sensations while
eating to take stock of
cues and stimuli that are informing your
feeding habits
and so during the day you're not like
necessarily trying to hit a particular
macro target or a calorie target but at
the end of the day you go through and
retrospectively kind of make an account
of okay what did i eat today
and you kind of match that up with
the observations related to intuitive
eating and mindful eating and you might
come away with some really helpful
strategies and you might notice for
example wow
i ate based on my hunger and satiety
cues today as i always do but why was my
calorie intake 500 calories higher than
normal you know and you might be able to
go back and make some really useful
inferences based on well what kind of
cues were informing my my decisions
today related to the onset of eating and
the cessation of eating and my food
choices so i i think that in certain
contexts you can merge some of these
concepts together and based on the
actual definitions of intuitive eating
and mindful eating they need not
necessarily be viewed as completely
inappropriate in the context of someone
who is intentionally working to lose
weight yeah i think i think it's worth
just kind of
kind of driving home the idea that uh
like just because a treatment or
intervention
was developed for one particular purpose
that doesn't mean it can't also be
useful for another purpose like
for example viagra was being developed
as a blood pressure medication that
doesn't mean it doesn't also make your
dick hard uh so
this is kind of the
i feel like that's ace
somewhat apt metaphor may be a bad
metaphor yeah i'm not totally sure but i
i think i think it's a similar concept
like regardless of what the idea of
intuitive eating like regardless of the
the
explicit purpose it was initially
developed for that doesn't mean that
those
same ideas and concepts can't have
utility and purchase outside of that
initial context exactly yeah and i i
said to the um the person who asked this
question um
they're like oh well this person was one
of the kind of co-creators of intuitive
eating and they wouldn't like the way
that you're that you're framing it
within that context and so i looked at
some of that content i was like
yeah it seems like their messaging is
pretty antithetical to the idea of
basically ever intentionally pursuing a
weight loss goal um so we disagree on
that and that's okay but you know we the
intervention can be applied in different
contexts and
you know like you said even if it wasn't
designed for a very specific application
it doesn't mean it has no utility within
that specific application i mean the the
people who developed most of the
statistical
procedures we used developed them to
verify the superiority of the white race
but like we can still use them for other
purposes yeah there is a very
a very tragic history of the
development of statistical techniques
now the t-test that was for beer that
was for beer
tests yeah it's a pass the t-test is
safe that was for beer students t-test
yeah but like there were a lot of folks
who back in the day when they were
developing statistical methods they were
like the chair of the department of
eugenics yeah like explicitly at
universities which is really messed up
uh so again yeah we can take the math
and leave literally all the rest correct
um so anyway uh another thing that came
up so what we're saying is that if
you're using intuitive eating for any
purpose other than weight loss you're a
eugenicist that's that's
not that's what you're that's what
you're saying no i i no
um but so then another question that
came up here was just about the idea of
like health at every size right that
came up in the conversation i i think
people have asked us about that before
um either directly or indirectly and i
think it's important to note that there
are kind of two tracks in the health at
every size debate
if we try to simplify it down to that
and like when it comes to these topics
intuitive eating mindful eating health
at every size body diversity like i'm in
no position to speak on behalf of them
or to like unilaterally define them but
we work in fitness people ask us about
these topics and you kind of have an
obligation to form
some working understanding of what they
mean to you and how they kind of fit
into the overall picture
um so health at every size sometimes
people kind of uh try to
really narrowly define it as like well
if you support this concept of health at
every size it means that you
fully and unequivocally reject any
connection between adiposity and any
cardiometabolic health outcome like some
people try to
like kind of
make that the only possible application
of the concept of health at every size
but alternatively like there are a lot
of people who view health at every size
quite differently and say well
there's really a couple main things
first of all there's tremendous bias
against people with larger bodies in
health care and outside of health care
and that is an inherently unproductive
and deleterious thing and just an unkind
thing so one one aspect is focusing on
rectifying the wrong of that weight bias
and another aspect is the fact that
people at any body size can make
proactive steps toward improving their
health through a variety of behavioral
modifications that need not explicitly
be weight loss right so
a person at any size can make decisions
to
increase their physical activity level
to increase their consumption of
vegetables right to
aim to increase their fiber intake right
there are a lot of behavioral
modifications that can occur
at any size to improve health and so i
think it's important like in fitness
there's a lot of really toxic
information about there
out there about health at every size
people really criticizing it and saying
like no like everyone needs to be
you know 12 body fat if you're a man or
20 percent if you're a female
or if you're a woman uh like there's a
lot of really toxic chatter about health
at every size and trying to
uh
trying to really straw man it into the
worst possible argument or the least
compatible with the evidence um and so
yeah i think
that's kind of my my perspective on
health at every size is like i my focus
when it comes to that discussion is like
removing bias against people with large
bodies with high body weight high bmis
etc removing that bias proactively
working against that bias and focusing
on strategies that can be implemented by
anybody to make proactive steps toward
health
um and then the the other thing that
came up was uh body positivity in that
conversation and again this is something
that comes up all over fitness circles
uh
usually like i hate that it's this way
but this conversation always comes up
when somebody with a bmi of like 26 is
on the cover of a magazine
and a bunch of people [ __ ] lose their
mind
and like dude
if you're checking out at the grocery
store and you see a magazine cover and
the the person on it has a bmi of
you know
25.4
27 god forbid even 30.3 if that ruins
your day
and you have to like get on twitter and
get banned for a week because of it
dude you gotta work on that like that
that is not healthy for you it is in
your own best interest to figure out
why this is ruining your day yeah uh but
anyway the way i view body positivity
and body diversity as a fitness
professional well and the other thing
i'll say is just like if
if you're the type of person who's gonna
get online and post about that like you
know
like you said if uh if a model with a
bmi of 27 makes it to the cover of
sports illustrated and you're like
this is
this is a [ __ ] travesty i need to
sound off about this on instagram and
how how much this
uh reflects the degeneration of our
society and culture the thing is the
person on the cover of that magazine
isn't going to see your post
but
you have
probably dozens of people in your life
who know you
who are bigger than that person
who
are going to see that
and it's going to make them feel like
[ __ ] and then like if you are someone
who you know let's say let's say you are
a good coach who specializes in weight
loss
those are people who maybe you would
have previously been able to help who
are now never going to [ __ ] talk to
you like
you you are signaling like i am not
someone who
cares about you or can empathize with
you like i
i don't think people who look like you
should be visible in public right and so
like it's
it's it's cruel at worst and
self-defeating at best yeah and that's
even something i've thought about like
my uh general predisposition is to be
a smart ass and to be self-deprecating
and one of the things i've tried to work
on is like in the past i might talk
about like oh back at when i was at this
weight and i was i looked at this
particular way like i back in the day i
would make self-deprecating jokes that i
never intended to be like generalizable
to other people and just be like oh yeah
like based on where i'm at now that's
where i was then but then i did think
about like well if you're like gonna say
oh my god when i was like 13 body fat
and i was a complete fat ass and it's
like well then like what does that say
to everyone listening to you who's
14 body fat you know like and it's just
a ridiculous thing to do oh i make a ton
of fat jokes on myself and it's only
when i'm the fattest person in the
conversation yeah otherwise i'm just
like well you know
i personally don't care about this i
think it's funny like i can have a laugh
at my own expense yeah but like
i need to i need to think about how this
other person might feel if i make that
joke yeah yeah so
um
yeah
like i said if if
if if you are that person who every time
you see a magazine cover and you you are
the person who is getting upset and
causing this discussion about body
positivity like for your own sake
try to explore that and work on that
um but like people will
bring up the question of like well how
does a fitness professional who makes
content about weight loss
view like the discussion related to body
positivity body diversity and first of
all i think they're super important i
think that bias against individuals with
overweight and obesity is like i said
inherently bad inherently
counterproductive inherently cruel uh
whether it's occurring within or outside
of the healthcare space
but i also don't think that you know we
should remove an individual's autonomy
when it comes to making their own
decisions about their health and
wellness related behaviors you know so
like
uh i think that
no person should ever be shamed or
guilted into changing their body
nor should they face any external
pressure to do that but as a fitness
professional what i want to do
like kind of my goal
is
you know i think it's a really positive
thing when people feel empowered to take
control of their own decisions and
behaviors and to pursue
the behaviors and goals that are
important to them personally and i think
in order to do that you need some
autonomy you need a sense of competence
self-efficacy and you need some source
of intrinsic motivation and so as a
fitness professional my goal explicitly
is to
not convince people what they ought to
do with their body shape or their body
size but to empower people with the
tools they might need so that they can
cultivate that autonomy that sense of
competence and self-efficacy and
intrinsic motivation i want people to
feel totally capable and empowered to do
whatever they wish with their body
weight their body composition and to
pursue whatever goal is important to
them whether it's performance body
composition health wellness whatever the
case might be
so i wanted to take a moment to kind of
discuss these topics because
you know they come up a lot in fitness
and usually not in the most productive
way you know some of those conversations
get really toxic and i think it was
important to clarify like first of all
what these things are to me even though
i'm not an authority on them
and just kind of how i approach them as
a fitness professional and i guess
by extension how i would encourage other
fitness professionals to approach that
people who have a big
audience or a big platform within
fitness like i think it's important to
keep some of these concepts in mind when
you're putting out content and when it
comes specifically to that original
question of you know
intuitive eating and mindful eating how
can that work within uh the kind of
fitness culture we know today
i do think that there is a way to
incorporate those as really helpful
strategies pretty much regardless of an
individual's goal whether it's weight
loss or otherwise
but but more importantly i'm i'm hoping
that the broader conversation in the
fitness world
about body positivity body diversity
health at every size i hope it starts to
trend a little bit more productive
um because the way those conversations
go these days is it gets a little ugly
yeah it's not great well i mean it's
like um
uh man
i don't even remember how long that how
long ago it was now like a year ago
maybe uh my my first uh visit at the gym
near my house where they they put me
through just like the initial screening
thing and you know i i told the guy
like hey what are you trying to
accomplish you know what like i'm just
trying to to like build some muscle
get some strength back haven't lifted in
a while recently broke my arm trying to
trying to get strength back in that arm
get range of motion back like that's
what i explicitly told the guy but like
i'm an overweight dude and just like
literally everything about that screen
was just like oh well you [ __ ] need
to lose weight and like here's how we're
gonna do that yeah i'm like i didn't
tell you i wanted to do that like that's
why why are you assuming this well dude
there's so many stories of people who
are going to a physician for
just completely unrelated [ __ ] they go
in there with a broken collarbone you
know they go there with a cut that needs
stitches
and the first thing the physician says
is uh wow you really need to lose some
weight anyway let's take a look at that
wound it's like
dude i got cut like yeah you know but
but the whole visit starts to become
like purely weight focused yeah you know
which is not not productive yeah so i'll
i'll obscure i mean like the so
one of the motivations for the idea of
health at every size like it's it's not
just like fitness stuff like it also
applies to like medical [ __ ] right um
and
like one of the important things you you
noted was like regardless of whether or
not it may be beneficial for some people
to lose weight independent of that there
are
almost always beneficial things people
could do for their health uh
other than losing weight like that that
is one positive thing that maybe they
could do but there's a whole laundry
list of other things
and so with like the idea of like weight
stigma in the in the medical system and
weight stigma among doctors and how that
can
like actively harm and contribute to
worse health outcomes for fat people um
so like i'm not going to give away any
any identifying information but like i
know someone who's
who's rather overweight uh in their late
twenties they went to the doctor and
like you know i'm not going to make a
medical diagnosis for this person but i
feel pretty [ __ ] confident about what
i'm about to say like their blood work
comes back and their ldl was like in the
400s which
i mean
you gotta go on a [ __ ] statin at that
point yeah and you know i'm not going to
prescribe that to him like i'm not a
medical doctor but you know for for a
[ __ ] doc that should be you know
maybe do a confirmatory test a month
later something to verify but like
whatever when your ldl is that high like
come on there's right there's one thing
you got to do there what did his doctor
tell him he said you know what
you got plenty of weight you need to
lose so like
lose some weight once you've done that
if your ldl hasn't come down then we can
maybe talk about getting you on a statin
and
brother like weight loss can
reduce ldl levels that's not going to
take you from 400 to 100 you know
like
and i told him i was like dude you know
i'm not going to tell you what drugs to
take or what to do about your health but
i would maybe encourage you to get a
second opinion about that because yeah i
mean
i i don't know how's that how's that
going to go if he doesn't lose weight
his doctor's just like not ever going to
prescribe a statin and let him die of
heart disease like what what's that
gonna look like you know and it's it's
[ __ ] insane and so like healthy and
people at every size would say like hey
regardless of whether this is a fat
person or not if their ldl is that
[ __ ] high give them a statin right
and and also like yeah you can also
focus on weight neutral things that
ought to be helpful there right so like
the don't give people different
standards of care depending on their
level of adiposity exactly yeah and like
i don't want people to misinterpret that
thinking that we're establishing a
dichotomy between lifestyle intervention
and medication right yeah but the
appropriate thing there as far as i
would i would expect i'm not medically
trained would be potentially weight loss
and a statin yeah why not behavioral
approaches plus the medication that's
literally designed for that yeah um but
yeah i mean
the thing that kills me is you'll you'll
see people who are like well i just
follow the data and i here's an
epidemiology paper on bmi therefore
you know
just do lifestyle stuff and and yeah
this this weight bias is a positive
thing in healthcare that should be
shaming people into weight loss and and
that's my
quote-unquote evidence-based perspective
but
what those people are missing is that in
like every area of medicine there is a
pragmatic balance to strike between
efficacy and effectiveness so when
you're going to approach a particular
treatment you don't just think what is
the
maximum upside if this is completed with
perfect adherence you have to consider
what is the likely success rate and what
is the realistic level of
adherence and compliance that can be
anticipated at the population level you
know so like we even have different
analytical approaches for this in
randomized controlled trials right so
like you'll open up an rct and they'll
have an intention to treat analysis and
a per protocol analysis because they
understand that the
effect of being told to do something is
different from the effect of
successfully completing it those are two
very different things that ought to be
analyzed and interpreted differently
and so when people kind of take this
approach that like oh yeah the
likelihood of success the likelihood of
a high level of adherence and compliance
that's not part of evidence-based
practice like all you have to do is say
hey lose some weight and that's going to
fix everything that actually is
antithetical to this balance that is
that is really struck in like every area
of medicine which is not just what is
the upside of successfully completing
this intervention but also
uh what is the likelihood that at the
population level this is going to be
completed with perfect success every
single time yeah there has to be a
balance there or just with a sufficient
level of success
that the net effect is more positive
than any number of alternatives exactly
yeah so so you have to like
and that's why people often talk about
this kind of weight neutral approach to
different health interventions is like
okay what is the success rate of this
person losing 25 of their body weight
and maintaining it for the next 40 years
based on the literature that's a low
probability yeah right but what's the
probability of me helping this person
become a little bit more physically
active making some swaps with their diet
and improving the overall health of
their nutrition habits and exercise
habits
pretty
substantially higher success rate for
that than saying yeah lose a quarter of
your body weight and maintain it forever
yeah you know it doesn't mean those
things are impossible
but you have to consider the probability
of success based on previous data
whenever you're talking about a
treatment right so that was a
long-winded and meandering conversation
but it basically started with a question
of like
how can one possibly pursue intuitive
eating in the context of a broader
weight loss goal
and then just kind of using that as a
jumping off point to discuss
questions that we've kind of indirectly
been kind of led toward but never really
addressed that fully on the podcast but
yeah i think it's important for the
fitness world to embrace body diversity
body positivity
health related interventions that don't
necessarily require weight loss
and then even eating strategies like
intuitive eating and mindful eating
there are ways to incorporate these
ideas within a very broad selection of
goals and most importantly people should
feel feel uh empowered to choose their
own goals and they should feel like they
have all the tools necessary to
accomplish whatever goals that they
select
all right to play us out uh this episode
went so much longer than expected and
that is par for the course to play us
out uh i had a funny little exchange
with a listener so i mentioned
previously that ohio i was stunned when
i moved to north carolina because
culture existed and that was new to me
being from ohio
and
a listener
was like hey dude ohio definitely has a
culture and i was like dude putting
spaghetti in your chili is not a culture
uh which is like cincinnati-style chili
it's it's spaghetti with some chili it's
very good but i was just kind of poking
fun at him and he said no i'm on the
other side of ohio and i was like
yeah car tires also is not a culture
and he admitted there was a statue of a
rubber worker directly outside of his
office
so proving my point it took me two
guesses to get exactly that close but
but uh in all seriousness i was being
hyperbolic with that but i was referring
to an actual empirical
observation that's i i think is really
interesting so if you google like
things about ohio and specifically
central ohio like the columbus area
you'll see that people refer to it as
america's test market or
test city usa
not because it's the leading distributor
of testosterone but
it is a test market where
basically companies decided several
decades ago like whatever works in
central ohio
will work in all of america because it
virtually has no independent culture of
its own it's like it's just this like
perfect little microcosm of a generic
version of the united states
so that that's what i was referring to
is that columbus is
this kind of universal test market and i
must say
it is awesome to live in a universal
test market uh
very under so like yeah did i miss out
on all those unique cultural aspects
that give a city its own kind of flavor
and vibe of course i did but
there were times in college when i was
in columbus and i'd be like
in a taco bell at 8 00 p.m eating off
the breakfast menu and being like what
the hell is happening here yeah and like
what you notice is when you start
traveling outside of columbus you'll
like
you'll go to a restaurant and be like
hey i'll get the salad bar and they're
like
we've never done a salad bar and we
never ever will and you start to realize
that all these like chains whether it's
like
retail
or restaurants whatever the case is you
have this unique offering of products
that are completely experimental and not
accessible anywhere else in the country
uh so while having uh that kind of
extremely generic usa culture in
columbus had some downsides you also got
to just try all this wacky experimental
stuff from major chains some of them
caught on some of them didn't uh but
yeah so living in columbus was a really
weird thing where you could just kind of
sample all of these
hypothetical ideas that may or may not
catch on
but one thing i will acknowledge though
the one culture that is strong in
central ohio
is the most important culture which is
lifting culture
so i don't know if people recognize this
but central ohio is like a hub
for strength [ __ ] so like the arnold
classic back when it was only in one
location it was in columbus now it's
kind of done
other stuff where it spreads out
rogue is is based out of central ohio
they make all the bars and equipment and
stuff westside barbell is in central
ohio elite fts is in central ohio
so if you're into lifting and boy was i
central ohio is the place to be yes um
all right so i think that does it for
this episode of the stronger by science
podcast like i said we've got one more
this season then we're going to take our
little summer break
as always thank you for joining us and
we'll see you soon
thank you for listening to the stronger
by science podcast
if you enjoyed the podcast be sure to
sign up for our free newsletter to get
concise breakdowns of relevant research
as well as 28 free training programs for
all skill levels and all schedules
we hate spam just as much as you do so
we'll only email you when we have
something really interesting to share
with you
you can sign up for the free newsletter
at strongerbyscience.com
newsletter or just go to the stronger by
science homepage and click the free
programs button at the top
if you want to join in on the stronger
by science podcast conversation be sure
to check out our facebook group and our
subreddit the links for both are
provided in the description of today's
episode
finally please remember that we are not
medical doctors or registered dietitians
so before you make any changes to your
exercise or nutrition habits be sure to
check with a qualified health care
professional
once again thank you for listening and
we will be back soon with another
episode of the stronger by science
podcast
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you